pounding has recorded the highest number
of fatalities
in the last 24 hour cycle the morning
sun
brings little relief in a south african
township called alexandra
the storm has arrived in the frigid
depths of winter
and the people who live here are
virtually defenseless
we found hundreds of people seeking
coveted tests and treatment
at the local clinic and the length of
this queue
would test anyone's endurance
in my community we have we have to bury
a lot of people
and it it's it's hard for us it's really
hard because they're really close to us
and
we use the same tap or the same toilets
you know
and we don't have any sanitation inside
the
toilets you see so we're really scared
this country has the highest rate of
infection on the african continent
but the reality on the streets is even
worse than that
we joined dimpo mateo on her second
attempt to get a covid test
she had diarrhea a fever and shortness
of breath
do you think you will be able to get a
covert test today
by the look of things i don't think i'll
get i don't think i'll be tested today
you can see how long is the queue people
are too many
yeah it makes you wonder whether we
really know how bad
this crisis is bad it's really bad
i mean people don't know if they are
sick or not
you know so obviously maybe the feeders
are happy
it's one of the most densely populated
communities
in the country half a million people
living in a couple of square miles
including dimpo's family who share a
tiny plot
with five other households her sister
neo
told me she's got exactly the same
symptoms
can you isolate here not really because
there's seven of us in the house
and it's not it's not really possible
how many people live in this compound
there's
four people in that house and there's
two in the
and in that other house there's five of
them oh and there's an old man that
lives alone in the other
about 19. 19 people in this this
compound yeah
neo tried to get a covet test at three
local clinics
eventually she paid at a private
facility and tested
positive i'm scared that my mom is old
you know and she's the one who's busy
bringing me food whatever and she brings
it
so if i infect her i feel very bad yes
it's not a good situation it's not a
good situation and you can see
alexander you've got small houses how
are you going to isolate yourself as an
elderly person from
the other person who's got coffee
chronic
in the middle the fear and insecurity
which cloaks the residents of this
community is shared
by those charged with looking after them
covert 19 tests are provided to
hard-pressed community health workers
but they have to wait for weeks to get
the results
so as it have tested last week i'm still
waiting for my results
i don't know when they will be back we
have a week right now
you you could be positive right now i
don't know you see
and you're working in the community i'm
pleased with the community i'm pleased
with my colleagues
so that this is a problem isn't it you
see so that's a problem you can't test
and come back to work
government ministers have raised the
alarm as the total number of infected
hurdles towards half a million but the
people of alexandria know
everyone's at risk as they grapple for
ways to survive
john sparks sky news johannesburg